hello my name is Kanika Singh and I work
as r d scientist at Thermo Fisher
Scientific
I appreciate you all being here for this
webinar
today I'm going to talk about efficient
culturing of human mesenchymal stroma
cells for cell therapy research
in this webinar you will learn the
basics of cell therapy and mesenchymal's
promo cells
I will introduce you to two specialized
surfaces to culture embassies for cell
therapy research
so there are three pillars of
Therapeutics
the first one consists of small
molecules
small molecules are extracted or
synthesized chemical compounds which are
used in traditional drugs and examples
are aspirant penicillin Etc
the second pillar consists of biologics
a biopharmaceutical also known as
biologics are nothing but the drug
products manufactured in extracted form
or semi-synthesized from biological
sources
they typically have biological functions
and examples are monoclonal antibodies
proteins and peptides like insulin and
nucleic acids which includes DNA and RNA
vaccines
the third and final pillar is cell and
gene therapy
so Cell Therapy utilizes living cells
from the patient or a donor for
treatment
and this complex technology is quickly
evolving and offers hope for many who
often have no other treatment option
so what exactly is cell therapy
with living cells from the patient or a
donor Cell Therapy replaces damaged or
diseases
or stimulates the body's immune response
or regeneration
it can also serve as a delivery vehicle
for genetics and molecular therapies to
the targets
as you can see on the right there are
different types of cells used for cell
therapy
the first one is differentiated adult
cells which are isolated directly from
Human tissue
the next is immune cells example for
which are car T cells which are a major
segment of immune therapy these days and
in cases
and finally stem cells which includes
hematopoietic stem cells neural stem
cells induce pluripotent stem cells
and mesenchymal stromal cells Etc
and today we are going to talk about
mesenchymal stromasils
what are embassies
so mscs are multipotent stem cells that
can self-renew and differentiate into
many cell types
these cells can be easily isolated from
numerous sources and are relatively easy
to culture in vitro
so as per the guidelines of
international Society for cell and gene
therapy mesenchymal stromal cells or
mscs they have a fibroblast-like
morphology
these cells can be grown on tissue
culture treated surface and are adherent
in nature
they express certain CD markers like
cd105 cd73 and ct90
and do not have certain markers like CD
45 34 hladr
Etc on their surface
like I mentioned in the previous slide
they have a potential to differentiate
into multiple lineages like osteoblasts
adipocytes and chondroblasts
now that we have understood or we have
defined what mscs are let's understand
why human mesenchymistromal cells are
used for therapeutic applications
so
human
mesenchymistromal cells they have
regenerative properties so they home to
the site of damaged tissue and
facilitate its repair
they have a better crime signaling
effect to stimulate to tissue specific
stem cell renewal angiogenesis fibrosis
and apoptosis
these cells also demonstrate
immunomodulatory effects
so by direct contact or by the secretion
of several factors they modulate the
function of immune effector cells such
as T cells
now that we have understood what mscs
are and why do we use mscs for
therapeutic application let's take a
look on statistical data present for MSC
clinical research
so overall mscs have been used for at
least a decade in clinical trials and
there has been around thousand MSC
trials focusing on several disease
indications
there is still some skepticism in the
field using mscs as a therapeutic option
because of the small sampling size or
statistical insignificance
and due to this reason many MSC clinical
trials do not make it past early phase
into commercialization
however there is a general consensus on
safety while administrating mscs because
they lack hldr expression and are
suitable for allogenic therapy
and as you can see in the graph for gvhd
and musculoskeletal diseases where there
are no available treatment
mscs have shown a positive impact
so
with this data it is pretty clear that
mscs have been used in like in an
accelerating manner have been used in
Translation research and it is very
important to provide precise cultural
condition for their growth and
proliferation
now to talk about the growth and
proliferation of human mesenchymistromal
cells we know that there are two
possible ways to Culture Your mscs in
vitro firstly
for growing your cells either you can
use media containing serum to grow your
mscs
or you can seed yourselves on an ECM
coated surface and you can use a media
which does not contain FPS
now as we know that animal origin serum
carries a risk of zoonotic transmission
and it could promote chronic
inflammation
and sometimes when we use ECM in our
culture for coating the surfaces it also
could carry a risk of unwanted immune
response
so in order for your mscs for
translation into clinical research
purpose it is ideal to avoid the usage
of serum and ECM in the culture
so we all know that there are many
delivery methods available for MSC
therapy the first and the simplest and
the most inexpensive method is to trade
patients by injecting isolated mscs
the second one is using biological
scaffolds which includes the
transplantation of cells to disease site
using biodegradable materials
and the Final Approach is scaffold free
systems
as I already mentioned that the presence
of serum and ECM in culture has
potential risks associated with it and
it is important to culture mscs in a
risk-free environment if we want to
translate them for self-therapy research
so to cater this requirement
Home official offers a specialized
surface called nanklon Supra surface
so this surface is a high attachment
surface which is plasma treated which
allows the support which allows and
supports the growth of mscs in the
absence of any ECM coating and we can
use serum free and xenofree media for
growing our cells
now I'll take you through a set of
experiments we did in order to showcase
the usage of nankron supra surface for
culturing different MSC so we have used
three different types of mscs for the
experiment the first one is adipose
tissue derived ads the second is water
and jelly mscs or wjmscs and the third
one is bone marrow derived mscs
so these three cell types have been
cultured on three different surfaces the
first surface is non-clone Delta surface
which is not coated with any ECM so to
clarify non clone Delta is the regular
plastic surface you use in your lab to
grow your cells and the cell start is
the ECM coating which we are going to
talk about so the first surface we took
we did not coat it with any ECM
the second surface is non-clone Delta
surface coated with say start and the
third surface is the nankron Supra
surface which is of course not coated
with any PCM
so after growing our cells these three
types of cells on these surfaces we did
certain Downstream experiments so we
checked for the morphology of the cells
how do they look like once they are
grown on these surfaces what is the
doubling time and the viability of the
cells
uh we also did the phenotypic
characterization so if you are growing
the cells on a regular surface with ECM
coating
what is the expression of surface marker
that we compared with the cells grown on
Supra surface
and lastly we assessed the differential
potential of these cells so if there is
any change in the differential potential
when the cells are grown on Supra
surface in the absence of ECM
so let's take a look at the results
so on your left you can see the
morphology of all the three cell types
we have taken
so on the extreme left in the absence of
ECM because the media does not contain
any FPS the cells could not survive
in the middle panel you can see wherein
ECM coating was done in the presence of
media without FPS cells could Thrive
properly
and finally on nankron Supra surface
where there was no ECM coating done and
the media which was used did not have
FPS in it
the cells could proliferate nicely so
the morphology on Delta with ECM coating
it looked exactly similar to the Supra
surface wherein there was no coating
involved
on the right you would see the doubling
time of the cells grown on Delta surface
with ECM coating versus Supra surface
and as you can see here there wasn't a
significant difference between the
doubling time of the cells grown on
these two surfaces
we also checked for the cell viability
of the cells uh take grown on these
surfaces and in all the cases the
viability was above 95 percent
so this particular set of data
told us that the mscs can be grown
properly on nanklon Supra surface and
their morphology and cell health is
preserved on this surface
foreign
so in the next experiment we wanted to
check the expression of surface markers
on the cells taken from Supra surface
versus delta surface which was coated
with ECM and as you can see here the
expression of CD 73
cd90105 and 44 was similar in both the
cases so basically this experiment
proved that the when the cells are grown
on Supra surface the expression of the
surface marker remains unchanged so the
data which you are seeing here is from
bmmses but we have done the same
experiment for adses and wgmses and the
results were similar
so the final experiment we did was to
check for the differentiation potential
of the cells taken out from Supra
surface as compared to the cells which
were grown on Delta coated with ECM
coating
so as you can see here when the cells
were stained or the lipid droplets were
stained using oil Red O
in all the three cases for adscs WJ and
bmmcs the results were similar so
ideally
if you are growing your cells on Supra
surface without any ECM coating the
adipogenesis differentiation is not
getting hampered and you are getting a
good amount of differentiation as you
would get when you grow your cells on an
ECM coated surface
same way we did osteogenesis so for the
difference uh so for the visualization
part we we have we have used alizarin
red in order to stain the calcium
deposits and as you can see here for all
the three types of mscs the results are
similar in case of supra and Delta
surface
and finally for chondrogenesis we have
used Asian Bloom to stain mucin and as
you can see here for adsc's wjmscs and
bmmscs the results are comparable
so overall our results shows that that
nankloan Supra surface it supports the
growth of mscs under serum free
condition
it eliminates the need of any biological
coating for the cell attachment
and we are maintaining morphology growth
kinetics phenotypic characteristics and
differentiation potential of the cells
when cells are being grown on non-clone
Supra
so growing your mscs on this particular
surface would help you to provide
consistent results and would also
provide a smooth transition into
clinical research application while
maintaining high quality cells
efficacy of cell therapy is not only
based upon the cell quality and
phenotypes of the cells but also on
transplantation methodology
and researchers are using scaffold free
cell sheets these days in order to
enable viable cell grafting at the host
site
so there are multiple scaffold free cell
systems available so there are pH
responsive surfaces there are magnetic
responsive surfaces photoresponsive
surfaces thermal responsive surfaces Etc
and this in this talk we are going to
focus on thermal responsive surface
so like I mentioned
for formation of cell sheet and for the
harvesting purpose Thermo Fisher offers
a specialized surface called non-clon
upsell surface
and why this is a thermal responsive
surface or a temperature responsive
surface because
for this surface we have a special
coating of a temperature responsive
polymer so on a regular polystyrene
surface this polymer is first being
coated and this polymer has certain
properties so at 37 degrees this polymer
allows the attached cells to get
attached so you basically seed your
cells on this surface and once you keep
it in the incubator at 37 degrees your
cells will attach
but once you move it to room temperature
or around temperature 20 to 22 degree
Celsius
the the polymer it binds water and
swells which allows the cells to release
from the the surface so
just by keeping the dish or the surface
outside you can allow yourself to
dissociate you need not to add any kind
of dissociation reagent to your uh to to
your surface to dissociate the cells
so in this video you can see
how at 37 degrees the cells are attached
and once
the temperature is reduced the cells
tends to dissociate from the surface
okay so let's understand what a cell
sheet is so essentiate comprises of
uniformly distributed confluences with
preserved cell to cell Junctions and ECM
proteins
researchers these days are using cell
sheets for various purposes
so if you talk particularly about
mesenchymistromal cells
the sheets formed using these cells have
been used for bone and cartilage
regenerations
there are multiple studies wherein you
know in different animal models they
have been used for uh cardiac injuries
and then there are multiple uh research
papers wherein you will find the
application of these hmsc sheets for
tissue repair regeneration as well as
wound healing
okay so how to fabricate a cell sheet so
how to use upsell surface in order to to
make a sheet of
any kind so first of all we have to
start with a confluent cell culture we
have to seed ourselves in a way that
after a certain period of time we get
a fully confluent uh confluential layer
of cells on that surface
in such a way that there is a tight
Junction between these cells and which
would help them like to become loose
and then this sheet can be harvested
using a supportive membrane so the
entire procedure I'll explain you in the
next slide
so to begin with we are First supposed
to seat the cells onto the surface so
this particular surface is available in
multiple formats you can get 35 mm dish
100 mm dish and a 60 mm dish we also
have six well plates
for the same
along with the product you will also get
a supportive membrane for the
transferring of the sheets so first what
you'll do is you will seed your cells
onto the surface once the cells are
confluent you'll keep them at room
temperature
so at so once they'll start to get
loosen up because of the room
temperature you will put your shifter
like the supporting membrane or we call
it as cell shifter on the on this layer
of cells then after some time you will
just peel it off so what will happen is
along with the cell shifter or the
supporting membrane the layer of cells
will also come off so as you can see in
the last uh illustration below the dark
green ones are the cells and on the top
you can see the cell shifter and this uh
and this sheet can be transferred to the
host surface I'll just play a video to
show to give you a quick uh glance on
how it is done
so there's a dish you remove the media
first
you keep it at room temperature
put the cell shifter on you peel it off
and then you transfer it to the host
surface and then finally you put some
media on top and then remove or peel off
the cell shifter or the supporting
membrane so like this the cell sheet
which we have grown on the upsell
surface can be transferred to the host
surface
okay so Thermo Fisher offers
a specialized surface called nunc upsell
surface which is a temperature
responsive surface which helps in the
fabrication of cell sheets so this
particular surface is coated with a
specialized polymer which is a
temperature responsive polymer which has
a special property to allow the cells to
attach
at 37 degree celsius and once you keep
the surface outside at room temperature
at around 20 to 22 degrees
the uh the the polymer allows the cells
to dissociate from it you need not to
add any trypsin or any other
dissociation reagents to dissociate
yourself but just by the reduction of
temperature you can take off your cells
so along with the cells the ECM also
comes so as you can see here at 37
degrees the cells were attached and once
the temperature is reduced the cells
will dissociate along with their ECM
to show how to fabricate and harvest
sachet using upsell surface the data you
see here is from WJ mscs so what we have
done is we have first seeded wjmscs on
the upsell surface we grew them until
they reached a certain conference level
then we kept the sheet at room
temperature for them to dissociate from
the surface automatically we then
overlaid style shifter on top of it and
then as you can see here in the third
picture all the cells got attached to
the cell shifter and nothing was left at
the bottom these cells would then
transferred to the host surface where
they got attached because of the ECM
protein which Still Remains intact as I
mentioned in the previous slide
and once these cells were transferred
they were characterized using different
antibodies and live dead States in order
to confirm their viability
okay to ensure whether the sheet which
we have transferred is live or not we
stain them using live and dead stain and
as you can see here the green cells are
all life cells and then there were few
red cells which were dead so this
particular result showed that the cells
which we have transferred or the sheet
which we have transferred they are all
life
in order to see for the expression of
ECM proteins we stain them using
collagen 1A antibody and fibronectin
antibodies so as you can see here the
expression of collagenate and
fibronectin is there in the transfer
sheet so
we also did falloutin staining of these
cell sheet and here is the data
now on the right you would see a triple
layer sheet so
once you form a single sheet using the
upsell surface you can use it to stack
it up
so what we have done here is we made
three separate sheets using the upsell
surface and then layered them on top of
each other and prior to which we have
stained them with a cell tracker so
green red and blue so these three colors
which you are seeing are from the cell
tracker and you can layer them up and
after cross sectional after cross
sectioning them you can view them like
this
so in the same manner you can stack as
many sheets as you want depending upon
the experiment and you can transfer it
to the host surface
for your uh
for your purpose
so overall upsell surface can be used to
fabricate cell sheets
which can be targeted on the damaged
area and they can be used for repair and
regeneration research
and the harvested sell sheet as I showed
in the data it preserves ECM cell to
cell Junction and cell ECM Junctions
which are very important for an
effective cell therapy
like I mentioned we do not need any
dissociation enzymes for harvesting the
cells so we
ultimately preserves the silver ability
and the surface marker expression
so
so for an efficient culturing of mscs
or cell therapy research Thermo fissure
provides you
a number of products
we have media for you which is serum and
xenofree
we have different plastic surfaces like
Supra surface upsell surface data
surface and many more
also we have mesenchymal stromal cells
in our portfolio which would help to
which would help in your cell therapy
research
if you want to know more about our
products you can explore our website
www.thermofisher.com and explore all the
products available for cell therapy
research
it has been a pleasure delivering this
talk
please reach out to us for any questions
and queries we'll be glad to help you
out thank you